that just don't make sense to regular
people
and we find out now that the first guy
to stand up to the tyrants gets crushed
de Blasio and now Cuomo have told the
people of Staten Island New York City
and the country that if you speak up to
the emperor you get crushed
in the last week just to give you a
timeline Lou gel Amino one of the finest
criminal defense attorneys around and
Mark fonte who represent Dan and Mack
Max Pub Lou was served with Lou was
charged with a misdemeanor for trying to
be a lawyer all political leaders came
here to try to stand up for the guys and
the restaurants and the movement and
Andrew Lanza was nearly handcuffed in
front of Max Pub for trying to stand
with the people
the other night we found out that it was
a political Ambush more details will
come your way on what's happened but
it's A Tale of Two Cities
Walmart just announced they're paying
700 million dollars in bonuses in Staten
Island restaurant owners are getting
arrested two times in a week for trying
to make a hundred bucks
the ignorance is so high that on
National Television
they find it funny that small business
owners are trying to feed their families
while the millionaires sit in their
perch I'll say it again if I thought
anyone here intentionally tried to hurt
a New York City police officer I would
never be standing before you
you're going to hear now
um from luge alamino who's the criminal
defense attorney for Dan he's also the
attorney for the Staten Island
Restaurant Association and Max Pub this
is a patriot I've known my whole life
he's put his name his life his business
his practice on the line to stand up for
what's right and freedom Lou's going to
speak You're Going to Hear Dan's side of
the story for now
um and then Keith mcelharney the founder
and owner of Max Pub is going to give
you his side of the story so thank you
all for coming Lou gelamino
thank you all uh myself blue gel Amino
and my partner Mark fonte
um are representing Dan in his criminal
matter and also Max Public House in
their civil matters against the city uh
we've been standing up for small
restaurant owners and small business
owners in this city for the last nine
months and we will continue to do so
um today Dan is going to make a very
very short statement regarding his
situation then Keith is going to make a
statement regarding the pub and then I
will ask and take any questions for a
short period of time thank you
I have nothing but respect for the NYPD
and other law enforcement
I think when you find at the end of the
investigation you will find that I did
nothing wrong and I have nothing but
respect for NYPD
thanks for coming out today
morning
I'm Keith macalani a lifelong Staten
Islander I have a fiance and three kids
we are a regular blue collar family like
every Irish kid I ever dreamed like
every other kid all I ever dreamed was
opening my own Pub
why other people were dreaming of being
firemen or police officers I always
dreamed of being a bar owner
we worked hard porn in our life savings
and after three months we got shut down
by an arbitrary set of rules I respect
kovit I don't respect the corruption
overreach and arbitrary color zones that
are killing all my friends
establishments here and across the
country
the fact we are all come out here today
you will find that we are here cause of
Cuomo and de Blasio trying to crush the
little man who dare to speak up
many people's families continue to be
hurt by The Tyranny and my prayers are
with you with them all
but I will leave you with this political
leave you with this political ambush
will be figured out by our great
attorneys
but as the owner and just the family man
following the Stream
this governor and mayor are not going to
take my best friend and my Pub
out of respect to Law and Order
we will take the next few days to
regroup but I can assure the fight to
reopen Max public house and for the rest
of small business owners will continue
the dream lives on
uh
Community activist Scott libato
um
this is a big fight people this is a
huge fight and it's about the emperor
like John said squashing the little man
it's not fair yes the situation is ugly
but it is not fair what's happening to
the small businesses and I'm going to
tell you right now the famous lines of
captain Perry in the Battle of Lake Erie
men do not give up the ship and we will
not give up this ship
first I want to tell everybody I didn't
use the word great when writing that to
describe his attorneys but thank you
yeah good question
yes
when we first got here and talked to
Keith this is small business standing up
fighting trying to feed his family
um seems like it evolves uh two nights
ago what happened if you can tell us
because Danny said he did nothing wrong
the sheriff's department has given us a
statement saying they tried to arrest
him he hit one of their deputies with
his car Deputy went up on the hood has
broken leg is that a lie
the deputies do not have broken legs
that's an outright lie one of the
deputies injured his ankle either he
tore a ligament or something we still
don't know the extent but the fact that
that they lied and went out on a press
release to all of you saying that he
broke his legs is an outrageous outright
lie completely confirmed so what
happened
I'm gonna all I can tell you is this we
have an investigation going on we have
80 percent of it on video within the
four minutes of Danny leaving this place
and from the time he was hauled away was
four minutes
we have video of the end of it almost 80
percent of it
at no time was there an ambulance on
team on scene at no time can you see an
officer injured they had 15 unmarked
police cars
that came in uh not police cars let me
rephrase that sheriff's deputies
unmarked cars they came in swept Danny
away in four minutes like he was Osama
bin Laden in a CIA Black Ops and in four
minutes you see nothing else on the
scene not a not a an officer not a
sheriff's deputy interviewing Witnesses
not an ambulance not an offer sit down
ambulances never came to the scene in
four minutes he walked and the scene was
completely cleaned up like this was some
type of CI Black Op operations
over cheeseburgers
it that's what it seems It's Over
cheeseburgers and beer why would they do
this I have no idea you know why they
did this because they're not trained in
my life NYPD makes arrests in this city
when it comes to criminality
NYPD was not involved in this in their
slightest they want no part of it either
to the state troopers
the officers could have just approached
him in front of the place the night
before when he got arrested or two
nights before then he put out his hands
and said arrest me
I can tell you that's not the way it was
effectuated here it happened two blocks
away not in front of this building on a
dark Street where two big Burly offices
came out between a parkour from behind
him and yelled presti hey presti and
started running at him that's what
started the whole set of events it
wasn't two offices in uniforms waving
their badges in front of them saying hey
can we talk to you that's what started
the whole events and that's pretty much
all on tape
not identify themselves as Sheriff's
officers it's actually in the police
complaint that was drawn up against Mr
Preston you can read it yourselves you
guys
we will uh after the investigation is
complete we'll re we'll release our
video we have about 84 percent of it on
tape we do not have the first three
minutes on first minute and a half uh
we're looking for that video now when
the deputy was injured we don't we don't
know we don't I can tell you I can tell
you I I the the claims we have
investigated that part of it and it was
presented to us that he only hurt his
ankle I can assure people he did not
break his legs and I can tell you why
because Mr Presley was released with
Nobel
if he ran after a shot if he ran over a
sheriff's deputy they would have asked
for a half a million dollars in Bell the
DA's office has been nothing but
Cooperative with us I hope they will
continue to be cooperative has gone
forward I'm sure they will
consider the sharks that we used to be
real fast
I'm never gonna I'm not gonna disparage
any law enforcement but they certainly
do not effectuate criminal arrests here
in New York City and the like I said the
NYPD was nowhere to be found in New York
I think the rest of America has to
understand in New York City
sheriff's deputies are not like the rest
of the country
they're basically Revenue collectors
and they do civil enforcement they do
not do criminal enforcement myself and
my partner Mark fonte have been
practicing criminal law for over 40
years between us we have never dealt
with a sheriff's deputy in a criminal
case this is the first time
an agenda against Mac
I think you can answer that question
yourself
well I think at a respect for Law and
Order and the respect for the fellow
restaurant owners and and small business
anywhere we're going to take a step back
for a couple days regroup and consider
our options but I certainly
will tell you this Danny and Keith are
not giving up the fight on behalf of
small business owners and and Max Public
House to reopen
saying talk to us about that because
obviously that was one of the reasons
why they they showed up oh Friday night
Friday night he was Friday night he
would this didn't happen Friday night
happened Saturday night right Friday
night there were a bunch of people that
wanted to celebrate the fact that Danny
was released by from prison they came in
they would serve they they would served
food there was drinking going on however
you do not have to wear a mask in a
restaurant maybe there was some lack of
social distance and exuberance but
that's no reason to come in and send a
hit squad of 20 unmarked cars to zoom
them away in three minutes like he's
Osama bin Laden
look like a bunch of babies
I think Mr tobacco should answer that
he's as a community activist you know
I'm I'm not part of the legal team I'm
just someone who's concerned about
watching our rights and freedoms get
taken away from us that's why I became
friends with these guys that's why I've
been supporting them and I kind of
almost feel like you know the ignorance
level is so high now
that you have mega millionaires who are
on the national Spotlight like the folks
on Saturday Night Live
and instead of making fun of their
friends and the local business owners
who are broke and crushed and bankrupt
instead of coming down here as fellow
Staten Islanders and standing up for
them and bringing a positive light to
this thing what they want to do is go on
national TV and try to humiliate the
little man when he's down and to me
that's quite disgusting and as I
mentioned before my dad was a member of
the NYPD
the king of Staten Island's dad was a
proud fireman and a great friend of mine
and I saw Staten Island is heavily come
out and support him his mom his family
and everyone else in a time of need
after 9 11 when I cried for his father
so when I hear stuff like this it hits
me emotionally when I think wow if you
came out of your perch and your affluent
neighborhood and came down here and told
the liberal left this is a good thing
because it's about our freedom and
liberty we probably wouldn't be standing
here today talking about a political
prisoner who was the victim of in my
view a political Ambush by the king and
his henchmen support plan tonight we're
hearing about a March right we don't
know about tonight right now the guy's
going to take a couple of minutes step
back see what the next move is what we
do know is there's support everywhere
and when the emperor really wants to
paint you badly they try to kill your
support with your own people how do you
do that you paint them as a criminal so
you're watching it right before your
eyes folks and you're going to find out
that what you're seeing here in Staten
Island New York is not America I'm going
to address tonight
again out of respect for the Heat and a
respectful law enforcement and what's
been going on the the
organizers of the March have canceled it
and that was at a complete respect for
Law and Order and what what's been
happening and I'm going to address uh
Saturday Night Live just a little bit I
just want everybody know we had 2 000
people here
in a peaceful respectful rally
they actually cleaned up when they left
we had 50 to 100 people cleaning up the
street when we left maybe Saturday Night
Live should be mocking the people that
rude that looted and rioted and
destroyed our great city of in Manhattan
and the rest of the great cities in this
country anybody else
well you know
restaurant owners are frustrated and
angry
I certainly support whatever decision
they make but I think each individual
restaurant should make that on their own
violence so if you if it will make Danny
make a statement one more time then I'll
answer a couple more questions
thanks for coming everyone I have
nothing but the utmost respect for the
NYPD and law enforcement
I think when the investigation is
complete you're going to find out that I
did nothing wrong
again we're just giving some time with
the investigation and that's what I'm
referring all questions to the lawyer
thanks
for the bar yes
the ball will be closed for the next
couple days again at a respect for law
enforcement we appreciate the support
from everybody but for at a respect for
law enforcement law and order at least
for a couple days and then we'll regroup
but we don't intend to give up the fight
at all
that
is
well my response to that is very simple
if we can go a block and a half and get
a cheeseburger this place should be open
if you can show me science if you my
response to that it's very simple if you
can go a block and a half and get a
cheeseburger which you can
okay if anybody can show me science that
the covet virus stops at the railroad
tracks we'd be more than happy to shut
down until then we'd like the same we'd
like the same weekend we'd like the same
we'd like the same consideration given
to the other half of Staten Island and
being able to serve out cheeseburgers
and I'll be a year
but by the way like Mr tobacco just
reminded me there's there's thousands of
people in the wall right now buying
candles and Christmas presents for their
friends and neighbors and family and God
bless them they should it's a great
holiday it's a blessing all right all we
want to do is serve a cheeseburger and a
beer in this restaurant and 20 unmarked
cars took him away for that reason so
I'm also I'm going to say thank you
thank you everybody thank you oh
cool